you
once upon our time there was an
earthquake but this one is the most
powerful ever recorded since the
invention of the Richter scale made it
possible for us to measure apocalyptic
warnings it took the continental shelf
these tremblings often caused floods
this Colossus did the reverse drew back
the ocean as a vast breath taken the
most secret level of our world ley
revealed the sea bidded wrecked ships
facades of houses Borum candelabra
toilet bowl pirate chests TV screen
mail-coach aircraft fuselage cannon
marble saucer Kalashnikov metal carapace
of a tourist busload baptismal font
automatic dishwasher computer swords
seized in barnacles coins turned to
stone the standard gaze raced among
these things the population who had fled
from there toppling houses to the
Maritim hills ran down where terrestrial
crash and Bella had terrified them there
was naked silence the saliva of the sea
listened upon these objects it has given
the time does not never did exist down
here where the materiality of the past
and the present as they lie has no
chronological order all this one all is
nothing or all is possible at once
people rush to take take take this was
when any time some time variable that
might be useful what was this
well someone one earth that must have
belonged to the rich it's mine now if
you don't grab what's over there someone
else will be slipped and slivered on
seaweed and sank in solis and gossiping
see plants gaped at them no one remark
that they were no fish the living
inhabitants of this unearthed had been
swept up and away with the water the
ordinary opportunity of looting shops
which was routine to people during the
political uprisings was no comparison
orgiastic joy gave men women and their
children strength to heave out of a
slime and sand what they did not know
wanted quickened their staggering gates
as they arranged and this was more than
profiting by happenstance it was rubbing
the part of nature before which they had
flamed helpless
taketake while grabbing they were able
to forget the RIC of their houses and
the loss of time bound positions there
they tested the silence were their shots
to one another and under these cries
like the cries of the absent seagulls
they didn't hear a distant approach of
sound rising as a great wind does and
then the sea came back engulfed them to
add to its treasury
that's what is known in television
coverage that really had nothing to show
but the pewter skin of the depths in
radio interviews with those few infirm
timid or prudent who'd not come down
from the hills and the newspaper
accounts of bodies but for some reason
the sea rejected washed up down the
coast somewhere but the writer knows
something no one else knows the sea
change of the imagination now listen
there's a man who has wanted a certain
object what all his life he has a lot of
things some of which his eye falls upon
often so he must be fond of some of
which she doesn't notice deliberately
that he probably shouldn't have acquired
that cannot cost off there's an
honorable imperious by and above his bed
head a Japanese print a hook was I the
Great Wave he doesn't really collect
oriental stuff although if it had been
on the wall facing him it might have
been more than a part of the furnishings
but it's been out of sight behind his
head for years all these things but not
the one he's a retired man long divorced
chosen and old but well-appointed villa
in the Maritim hills as a site from
which to turn his back on the assault of
the city a woman from the village cooks
and cleans and doesn't bother him with
any other communication it's a life
blessedly freed of excitement he's had
enough of that kind of disturbance
pleasurable or not but the sight from
his look out of what could never have
happened
never ever have been vouchsafed it's a
kind of command he's one of those who
are racing out over the glistening
seabed the past distresses Tricia one in
the same stripped bare like all the
other looters with whom he doesn't mix
has nothing in common he races from
object to object turning over the shards
of painted China the sculptures created
by destruction abandonment and rust the
Brian vintaged wine casks a plunged
racing motorcycle a dentist's chair his
stride lending on disintegrated human
ribs and metatarsals he doesn't identify
but unlike the others he takes nothing
until their ornate with traces of orange
brown seaweed stuck fast with necklace
shells and crenellations of red coral is
the object a mirror it's as if the
impossible is true he knew that was
where it was beneath the sea that's why
he didn't know what it was he could
never find it before it could be
revealed only about something that had
never happened the greatest paroxysm of
our earth ever measured on the Richter
scale
he takes it up the object the mirror the
sand pours off it's the water that was
the only bright glance left to its
streams from it he's taking it back with
him he's taking position at last and the
great wave comes from behind his bed
head and takes him his name well-known
in the former regime circles in the
capital is not among the survivors along
with him among the skeletons of the
latest victims with the ancient pirates
and fishermen there are those dropped
from planes during the dictatorship so
there with the accompanists of the sea
they would never be found who recognized
them that day where they lie no
carnation arose floats full of
Featherman five
you